the head of one of the most powerful
teachers unions is in the hot seat Randy
Weingarten refusing to apologize over
devastating school shutdowns during the
pandemic half of America's students are
behind an entire Academic Year because
of those closures Republicans demanding
answers over emails showing the teachers
union helped coordinate the cdc's school
reopening guidance Weingarten admitting
she worked with the agency but claims
her role is being way blown out of
proportion
to summarize that a aft was provided
with a full draft copy of the guidance
two weeks before publication suggested
line by line edits no we did not sir did
we did not suggest line by line edits to
the document
well
do you remember how many edits that you
suggested we suggested we we suggested
concept sir you know how many edits were
included
it's unusual for political union to have
such a role in in scientific guidance
process and hopefully we can find more
answers weingarson also forced to admit
that she had a direct line to CDC
director Rochelle valenski
I'm a member of Congress that's on two
committees that deal with this the CDC I
don't have a direct number to director
wilinski do you do I have director
wilinski's direct number yes yes I have
director windlinski's direct number well
hopefully she'll give it to me too the
school lockdown Fallout does not and
there Dr fauci is also brushing off any
responsibility for shutdowns telling the
New York Times quote show me a school
that I shut down and show me a factory
that I shut down never never I did never
I gave a public health recommendation
that echoed the cdc's recommendation and
people made a decision based on that so
a lot of things coming out today judge
we do know that the CDC wanted to open
schools Rachelle wolinski from the CDC
said she wanted to reopen schools and
all of a sudden she was admonished and
they said even though she was speaking
in front of the CDC backdrop that she
was actually speaking in her personal
capacity yes later on we find out that
these emails had exchanged so they're
kind of quibbling over splitting split
hairs here well they're they're
quibbling because they have nothing else
to do in terms of Defending themselves
look racial Rachel not Rachel wolinsky
Randy Weingarten this is a woman who
actually went to the Ukraine to this to
assess the evaluation of the damage to
education from the Russian war she was
more concerned about the kids in Ukraine
than she seems there appeared to have
been about the kids in the United States
who suffered the greatest loss in
Educational Learning since the beginning
of the 19th century in America there is
no question that what happened to our
children was a devastating thing in
terms of as they grow up as they compete
in this world they will be at a loss
compared to other countries now you know
she can say Randy Weingarten and and
that you know it was all about
protecting the kids that's hogwash she
wanted a metric so that as soon as a
teacher might be ill they would shut
down the schools it wasn't about the
kids it was a about the teachers and
they resisted the effort on the part of
parents to take their children and the
money to a school that was open and make
no mistake there were schools that were
open the Catholic schools the charter
schools there were all kinds of schools
but these were her decision and her
working with the CDC as they indicated
having the private number of Rachel
wolinsky who said it's safe enough to
open and then of course she got slapped
and they backed down and then and Randy
Weingarten had lobbies very successfully
for federal taxpayer dollars to go to
all of the schools which then were never
actually spent they're just sitting
there Sitting Waiting for more and and
think about what is what is the UFT and
the AFT do with their money they give
money to political parties absolutely
mostly the Democrat parties so while
they are taking that money and
collecting it for covid our kids are not
in school and the teachers would not
agree to to teach in the summertime so
that kids could get at least a jump up
meanwhile Dr fauci was is on CNN here he
is call for number two
it was a personification of me as a
person who essentially closed everything
down those with public health
recommendations that came from the CDC
but the initial decision early on in the
middle of that crisis I believe was the
right decision how long you kept them
closed really varied depending upon the
locale
I know you have a little one there she's
not of school age of course yeah but you
have a lot of friends who do have
friends that are have kids in school and
even they were saying this is out out of
control absolutely and we talk a lot
about the Exodus from Liberal cities or
liberal states to more conservative
States because of uh lower taxes but a
principal reason for that was schools
that people wanted to go to a place
where their kids would have the next two
years of school and some people are
coming back and some people have decided
that they want to stay there and
obviously all sorts of factors that go
into why you want to remain in a place
but it was a part of that conversation
and something that Randy Weingarten said
that I think is important though
this is about the teachers right the
kids are are important we're educating
them but if she had teachers who said we
are not going back into the classroom
what was she going to do and I think
that it comes back to and we talk about
this a lot the fact that we were just
not being told honestly what was going
on and this was from the start the
conversations about masks because they
didn't want people to go out and buy all
the masks that we didn't have them for
the doctors and people who were
essential workers I thought that was the
right call but we were continually told
something else and diverted our
attention to this place when it should
have been a more open and honest
conversation with adults about the
information that we have and I think
that's what people hold against Randy
Weingarten or what they hold against Dr
fauci and if you treat adults like
adults then everyone can make their own
decisions right including that if they
told us that we needed to leave the mass
for the doctors and the nurses I think
that we almost done that would not have
been a problem Greg President Biden also
weighed in on kids today or yesterday
listen here kids there's no such thing
as someone else's child
no such thing as someone else's child
our nation's children are all our
children are they I think that's so
moving
I really do but you missed that other
the second part he says you know there's
no such thing as someone else's child we
cut it off right before he said unless
it's my granddaughter oh this is the
baby
who's the baby of a stripper that all
bets are off he shouldn't be lecturing
anybody's hypocritical old fart uh that
that that hearing is about
accountability and it's important
because what went missing was
accountability that when the government
and the Tech Industries the media and
corporations all went in on one side uh
you realize that anything goes two weeks
to flatten the curve became two years
you could be you could extort people uh
for a on vaccines or on masks by using
their livelihood where they worked and
even if the even if the where you work
the people didn't like that they had to
do it because they were they had the
thumb on them from above what did the
media do well they led the charge by
smearing anybody who was anti-lockdown
or vax skeptical as a danger to America
uh they did what uh what kind of hawks
would do to the anti-war movement which
is they would paint you as a threat to
security just for voicing any kind of
opposition or saying hey you know maybe
this is going too far and the
consequences we kind of hit on them you
know the shutdowns have correlated with
multiple consequences suicides overdoses
dysmorphias I mean you wonder why so
many kids are confused about who they
are we'll leave them alone in a room
with a Tick-Tock influencer instead of a
teacher you know Gary is going to turn
into Glenda you know you just hope it
turns back and then uh and obviously the
shutdowns turned into dramatic upticks
and traffic fatalities that's another
thing that we don't talk about closed
thousands of businesses it killed
thousands of people needlessly because
being outside and being active would
reduce your Reliance on drugs and
alcohol I mean if we were a country and
and covid was a country we are at war
with Randy Weingarten would be tried as
a war criminal
that's a hypothetical absolutely he's
not she's not really a war criminals as
you do and analyze from your perch so so
I think that that statement from Joe
Biden is is really creepy
um of course you know the idea that
people don't have it's sort of like
saying the the quiet part out loud about
socialism because of course what is
social you know socialism believes that
people you know that people don't have
any relationships except the government
you don't have a family you don't have
parents you don't have children
everything goes directly to the
government
um which is a really frightening
terrifying thing that usually
politicians don't come out and say but
going back to what you said yes because
you know isn't that the whole problem
with the teachers unions is that the
decisions that they're making are about
the best interest of the teachers and
not what's in the best interest of the
children and so they were completely
obsessed with the idea that teachers
that teachers wouldn't show up that's
crazy and and by the way I know a lot of
teachers who who you know they're
concerned were concerned about covet but
they would never ever Place themselves
ahead of the interests of the children
and so I I think and then and then if
that is the position of the teachers
unions then why do the teachers unions
have this kind of power in government to
write the regulations about going back
to school or anything else for that
matter they shouldn't be allowed to have
any Authority at all so if I was
misunderstood and that they didn't care
about kids at all I certainly didn't
mean to intimate that I just meant that
her job was a lot more difficult than I
think people are making it out to be
they're just saying that she's you know
sits alone in a room and says we would
rather sit inside and be on Zoom all day
which is not what happened she had
thousands of people telling her that
they had pre-existing conditions they
were scared about this they remember the
deaths even when they got vaccines first
remember they didn't go back to school
and by the way of all the emails that
they found there was nothing about how
to keep the schools open it was never
about this the kids it was about the
teachers all right hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now